all right everybody I want to share one
more inspiring story before we close the
show this is what I'm liking
[Applause]
America competing to be the good
neighbor of the year of course there are
amazing neighbors across the world like
an eight-year-old girl in the UK who has
turned an unfortunate chapter of her
life into an inspiring children's book
this is Tiana who is regularly teased by
her classmates about her hair her mother
reminded Tiana that she was beautiful
and encouraged her to do something with
the sadness she was feeling which is
incredible mama and she did that so
Tiana wrote a book my Afro twin best
friends which has resonated with black
and brown kids around the world she's on
the line right now along with her mama
Dorothy what's going on y'all
yeah
thank you so much for joining us Tiana
I'm going to start with you is that you
were afraid to wear your hair naturally
yes Kelly I was really afraid to wear my
hair out partly because when I looked
around I saw that most of the pupils of
my school didn't have the same hair as
me and even more so one of the pupils of
the school said that I look like a lion
because of my hair but that made me feel
really sad
so in the pandemic my mum told me to use
that energy and write a lovely story and
so I decided to write my Afro twin best
friends
and the feedback I got was amazing
saying that I should keep going and that
just made me feel so happy
so much this is so cool Dorothy this
book resonates with all kinds of kids
right it does it resonates with kids and
adults and it was a journey for me just
teaching tear using Mrs word Smith
flashcards and it turns out she ended up
writing a whole book and some she's
actually publishing a second book as we
speak so I'm really really excited for
Tiana this is all her friends
great mom points man to tell your kid
because my kid I was six and eight year
old they experience bullying and they
experience you know mean kids and saying
mean stuff and and it's so important for
them to turn that around and into
something positive that can be helpful
it's such a healthy thing to teach your
kids so way to go being a great mom and
also Tiana way to go to listen and do so
and make something not so not so much
just for yourself Tiana but all kids
that might feel like that that maybe
can't write a book or don't feel as
outspoken as you are so thank you so
much for joining us ladies I'm liking
your posts right now right thank you
absolutely that's not all good
old doggies along partner pilot pen
makers of friction the go to eraseful
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate those creating fearlessly just
like y'all so they're gonna give you a
thousand dollars
[Applause]
Tiana is like I am getting something
cool
um well thank you all so much ladies and
thank you to all our good neighbors this
hour so amazing these are amazing
Sean Alicia Martin AJ Tyrique and Josue
y'all have a great day and if it's not
try and change it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]